just three years after he went missing a
mother is calling on las vegas to help
find her son jonathan hall went missing
back in 2019 his family and friends
still have no idea what happened to him
sasha loftus is here with more on their
continued plea for answers
denise and brian john's mom says she
still misses her son every second of
every day she's speaking out from across
the country hoping someone will know
something even after all this time
it's been three years since anna askbury
says her son jonathan hall vanished it's
some kind of pain that i can't even
describe to you the 30 year old was last
seen in 2019
and anna has spent every second since
then trying to figure out what happened
this is not my son he didn't just walk
away in this pier john moved to las
vegas 10 years ago and spent most of his
time here working at the las vegas queue
club perfecting his pool skills and
making friends like rossi plitz and i do
still put a christmas stocking out for
him every year here this was the last
place anyone saw him and plitz says she
and john's other co-workers still miss
him i'm always hoping that he's around
somewhere and after all this time
they're also still confused by his
seemingly sudden disappearance it's hard
i don't cry now but i know his mom
probably still does his mom tells me her
dream is to have him come back home
but no matter what she needs answers how
do you move on without closure
you can't and if john is still out there
she wants him to know she will never
stop searching your mama will never give
up until the day i die
john just had a birthday in february he
would now be 33 he's around 5 foot five
with blonde hair and green eyes if
you've seen him or have any information
please call metro police brian